i'm jane secker and you're listening to
episode 18 of storycast 21.
in 2005 in the aftermath of the seventh
of july london terror attacks the
shooting of jean-charles de menezes and
its subsequent handling led to
international outrage
as of 2021 the case remains mired in
controversy this is the shooting
my name is mark white i was the home
affairs correspondent at sky news for
more than 15 years
on the 22nd of july 2005 i was outside
oval tube station that was one of the
london underground stations that was at
the center of a security alert after a
failed bomb attack sifting through
hundreds of hours of cctv footage police
were able to come up with four
remarkably clear images men they
believed were involved in yesterday's
attack a group of islamic terrorists had
tried to detonate four bombs on the
london underground network and on a
double-decker bus in hackney
two weeks earlier on the 7th of july
four men had successfully blown up three
underground trades and a london bus in
tavistock square
and that killed 52 people and injured up
to a thousand others
then just two weeks later this carbon
copy attack wearing a new york t-shirt
this man was pictured running from the
oval tube station this man thankfully on
this occasion the bombs didn't fully
detonate at warren street tube this man
was seen leaving the station at 12 39
yesterday much of london was shut down
at that point as there was a very active
manhunt looking for four individuals who
the authorities believed were intent on
killing as many people as possible
while that manhunt was getting underway
police mistakenly identified the
brazilian national john charles de
menezes as the bomber who targeted
shepard's tube station that bomber
hussein osmond
in the rucksack osman used to carry his
bomb police found a gym membership card
that linked to an address in scotia road
in tulsa hill in south london
jean charles de menezes lived in scotia
road along with his cousin patricia de
silva in the block of flats that police
now had under surveillance
i arrived in london
i started to live in tulsa view
refugees
on the um two
young ladies yes
i come into london on
i live in sao paulo anderson in gonzaga
john charles de menezes was 27. he grew
up in rural countryside in southeastern
brazil
each year my mom would take us to
to spend time
in gonzaga
so i definitely can't say that we grew
up together because each year we meet
jean was a um
a very clever boy
very clever
boy he had grown up around agriculture
all of his life but had a real interest
in electronics
he wanted to pursue that he went to
college
in brazil and managed to get a diploma
which set him on the road to getting a
career and a skill set as an electrician
this then enabled him to move towards
europe to look for work in that field
john charles and his cousin patricia who
was then working as a cleaner just went
about their everyday business in scotia
road
[Music]
i was very happy because i liked to know
different things and places and the new
experiences they could have had no idea
that the block of flats they lived in
was under intense police surveillance
that it was linked to the wanted bomber
hussein osmond
armed plainclothes police officers had
been deployed near south london tube
stations as part of the wide-ranging
reaction to yesterday's attacks we just
had a failed set of bombings police were
in a race against time to find those
responsible
i remember that day
i i left the house to
to go to bromley
to working
so i left the house very early
very very yearly and this suspect from
the shepherd's bush incident was
pictured at westbourne park tube station
at 12 21. police released i was very
conscious about the the situation
in the city
yes i i
i was afraid as well yes because it
is everything it is it was very
discarded
for everyone the four bombers fled after
detonators ignited but failed to set off
their bombs peter sharp this particular
surveillance team was made up of police
surveillance officers but they were
assisted by some specialists from the
army as well
jean charles left the block of flats in
scotia road at 9 30 in the morning as
usual to go off to work
he was just wearing a denim jacket he
wasn't carrying any bags because he left
his tools with a colleague the day
before
a member of the military surveillance
team known as frank was in the van
watching the flat he'd half missed john
charles coming out he was unable to film
him because
as we understand it he was urinating in
a bottle in the back of the van
having caught a glimpse of sean charles
he tasked other surveillance teams to
follow the young brazilian who at this
time was heading towards brixton tube
station
certainly the authorities believed he
looked a bit like hussein osmond the
would-be bomber from the shepherds bush
underground train
and unbeknownst of course to john
charles there were surveillance teams
with him
along with others following in vehicles
behind us they tried to determine
whether this was indeed their suspect
osmond
all of the time they were reporting into
a command center where the operation was
being overseen by cressida dick who is
now of course the metropolitan police
commissioner
[Music]
significantly there were members of that
team we were reporting in that there was
no positive id on this individual as
they then continued to follow him
[Music]
john charles got to brixton tube station
he got out at that point
but because of all the security alerts
that were taking place across the
capital brixton tube station like a
number of other stations was closed so
he found himself going back onto another
bus heading this time towards stockwell
tube station
the undercover police actually thought
that what was going on here was classic
counter surveillance techniques being
deployed by a highly trained suspect now
that just upped the threat level and
their concern
john charles was just going about his
daily routine though doing nothing
different to
what every other commuter trying to get
into brixton station that morning was
doing which was trying to find an
alternative route
this young man had gone into stockwell
tube station
he picked up a paper from the stand had
gone through the ticket barrier
had walked down to the platform
and when the train came in he launched
into a bit of a truck to get to his
train get out get out eight or nine
undercover police guys with supported
talkies and handguns just start
screaming at
by the time the police rushed onto that
underground train jean charles de
menezes fate was already sealed
and then there was six or seven gunshots
behind us and then people just screaming
us to get out of the station
i have some breaking news coming from
the metropolitan police
we understand that there are reports
that police
have
shot a suspected suicide bomber in
south london according to i remember
after orkin
i went to library in bromley
and he stayed there choose the computer
internet witnesses say they saw armed
police officers chased a man onto a
northern line tube train that was
waiting on the platform with its doors
open i read
the the the police in london should
shoot to kill at a terrorist there have
been subsequent reports suggesting that
shots have been fired from a northern
line train this man was apparently taken
so after this
i left the library and they take a bus
to home was shot dead just a day after
failed bombing attacks on the london
transport system i was doing hourly half
hourly live updates outside oval when i
got a phone call to say there had been a
shooting at stockwell tube station
fortnight after terrorists killed 52
people now they thought that it was
linked to this operation to find those
responsible for the previous day's
failed bombing attacks
when
i got to church fletcher
i opened the door and there is two
friends of jian in in the living room
jesus is a friend
they was about to start a big job in
central london
and uh
i
i said today what's happening and oh uh
patricia we come here because the policy
um
coming to us
because he my
my telephony number was the last contact
in the
gym mobile
and they show a photo
from jian and they asked
do you know any family this man who we
need to contact the family of this man
in london
they said to us
jian was arrested because xi'an is a
suspect of terrorism
i said
what
after this i remember alex comey
alex is a cousin
patricia
you
have to come into
police station
i said to him why alex where was jian
coming to
police station patricia don't make
question
well our crime correspondent martin
brunt is in scotland yard and uh martin
joining us just as this breaking news
that we believe the man shot dead here
in stockwell was not connected to
yesterday's events what more can you
tell us
well i can only tell you that this is
what i'm picking up from security
sources that remember i i remember we
entered in this car and the day dropped
us in the police station it's believed
the man who was shot this morning at
stockwell tube wasn't one of those four
bombers that police are still hunting
they take us on the
to bring us to a room
with a at a table in the middle
i remember one um some drinks
on the table
and the
policy officer started to talk and he
started to talk talk talk i i couldn't
stand nothing
i have emerged as you
take my hands
and said to me
do you remember
the police shoot to kill
a terrorist a guy in istockwell station
did you see the news batteries if you
see yes i see but
they didn't kill a terrorist in
stockholm i said no
no they
confused jia with a terrorist
they killed ya
[Music]
the metropolitan police have released
the following statement we are now
satisfied that the man was not connected
with the incidents of thursday the 21st
of july for somebody to lose their life
in such circumstances is a tragedy and
one that the metropolitan police service
regrets i think there's no doubt that
senior management at scotland yard the
metropolitan police headquarters felt
really under siege during this whole
episode
it was a case of them battling down the
hatches trying as best they could to
avoid reputational damage in what had
been a catastrophic mistake i think the
met is playing out of its socks and i
think that
there's progress on this investigation
is extremely fast
i think there was definitely briefings
where information was getting out into
the public realm that just somehow
cast some kind of suspicion on a young
man who lost his life
at just 27 years of age having done
nothing wrong at all on friday morning
the man was followed by police into
stockwell tube station he refused to
stop and ran onto a train officers
shouted at passengers to get down as the
man was shot at close quarters and
killed
[Music]
they said oh he's jumped the buyers
under
his run
i think they want to justify
this
jean charles de menezes had gone through
the ticket barrier he'd walked down to
the platform the people that were
actually vaulting the barriers and
running down the escalators of the tube
station were the armed police and the
surveillance teams who were chasing
after jean charles
the passengers claim that mr dominezes
had remained in his seat
and that they never heard any officer
shout armed police
the armed police who run onto that
underground train believed in all
probability that they were going to die
as well that this man was going to
detonate a device and kill as many
people as possible
of course he wasn't he was an innocent
member of the public but the armed
police who opened fire that day just
didn't know that
certainly the authorities believed in
terms of the surveillance operation that
they mounted that he looked like hussein
osmond their main suspect
all officers following him on and off
buses had to go on was this grainy photo
of osman from a gym membership card
there was a very very vague similarity
if you want to boil it down to having
swarthy skin and perhaps not looking
european other than that i don't think
they look too similar
if my cars had a bomb with him he's had
to stop him before he gets a bus before
we get underground
not to let him take a bus go to the
underground then shoot him from behind
no one ended up in jail no officer who
opened fire was subject to any legal
sanction
none of the surveillance officers were
either for the menezes family and
supporters their joy at the conclusions
of the inquest jury is tempered by their
anger over what they claim was a deeply
flawed legal process
we had subsequent inquests and
investigations and appeals by the family
over the years demanding justice never
really feeling that they got that
justice
it was the view in all of the main legal
proceedings though that the police
were doing their job in trying
circumstances they got it
catastrophically wrong in parts but the
individual actions of officers were not
criminal
today we are
outraged
like
16 years
ago
it is still it's too much for us
and
[Music]
i don't know if one day
we will have justice
in my view i don't think so because i
think now it's
it is more impossible
[Music]
on july the 29th 2005 just over a week
after the shooting of jean charles
dominezes hussein osmond was arrested in
rome the four would-be bombers who
attempted the 7-7 style attack are
currently serving life sentences in the
uk
in 2016 the menezes family took the
british government to the european court
of human rights but failed in their bid
to bring about prosecutions
as of 2021 the case remains
controversial
the shooting was produced by rob mulhern
and tom gillespie for more information
go to sky news dot com forward slash
storycast 21
storycast is sky news's
multi-award-winning storytelling podcast
unit
next time
and i remember the very first lunch
break people were
kind of glaring at me
almost as if the things they heard i had
done i was really torn
in
how i was going to move forward with
this because i had built my life around
doing michael jackson and
it was up to those people in that jury
box what was going to come back
[Music]
you